Hey how's it goin' bros
My name is Peeeewdipie
Welcome back to
Abzuuu
part 3
This is..
A very cool game
I recommend you check out
part 1
what are you doin'
On part 3
If you haven't watched
part 2 and
whatever the fuck
You play as this little diver dude
Heeey backflip
that's like the best thing about the game, the backflips
We're about
toooo
ummm
go here
I completely forgot the controls
here we go
now
Bef.. When I played the game, it hasn't had been released yet so
the big feature about this game... I believe is that you can play it with a random stranger
So I think soon
I don't know when, it could happen at any point
Someone else is gonna join us
randomly
Someone will get to play
with the great
Poodiepie
and they won't even know about it!
I'm only sayin' that because that's how people commented about
when I was playing 'Journey'
people like:
"OMG, they could be playing with Pewdiepie, and they wouldn't even know about it"
How horrific *laugh*
No there are definitely worse things
oh shit if you tap "a", he he swims like a
boss
I-I always pick the worst places to end
the videos i am so sorry about that by
the way like this is clearly where I
should and not ended yet
alright so we say hi to the space blob I
think we have one or two more of these
and they're fairly short and 'Journey' was about two hours long but it's weird-  i can't
really feel the pace of this game the
same way
I've already played this I'm fucking
idiot ok let's try and get a little bit
more serious
all right i know i just started and I
mean I want to immerse myself a bit
that's that's what's beautiful about
this games after Rome
what are you doing whales? You can't swim without water.
Can someone just tell them please?
it was really great to see that so many
of you bros were as intrigued and
interested in this game as I was. It
really is impressive if you look at all
the fishes and be like it still runs so
smoothly
it feels like an alive world
look at it
look at all its beauty and all its colors
let's keep going in baby. I can not
control the camera angles properly, I'm so sorry
Okay it seems like it.
I'm just really worried because I want
someone else to join me
it's such a cute thing when you whoa
ok we found something.
Also keep commenting your theories about the story
I think it's really interesting
it made the fishes go outside the water
ok so it is actually a thing
cool
I think we're swimming up now let's
check it
so they gather the water from the bottom of that Sun. The Sun in the bottom of the
ocean and then they took that and they put in the ocean which made
th-the
fishes swim out and then that built the
great- I'm so sorry
the great coral thing
this is fantastic
I love the style of this
ok now
we need to keep going
oh yeah here's the water so there's
water in the water. I'm not crazy.
there is water in the water everyone
I mean technically it is possible. Alright, more
story i believe. It's a bit hard to see here.
So we came
that's us
And what do we do? The divers...
I don't know
fuck shit up probably
Are we the ones building these?
No....
That's just crazy
ok am I supposed to do something here?
I am. I should have done that first. Would have been a lot easier to see
I don't understand. I'm not even going to pretend that i do but like i said if you
have theories leave them in the comments
yeah let's keep going baby
ooh
ooh la la
so pretty
the absurd drinking game with Pewdiepie. Drink every time I compliment
how pretty the game is. It matters to me
okay?
shut up
ok sharks and shit got it
more sharks and shit. What the fuck is that
green eel?
that's terrifying... UGH it touched my face.
Disgusting! Have you seen eelslap .com?
That was literally the same thing that
happened. Ok we are being fed a little
bit of story in context here but i'm not
sure if I quite still get it
I remember 'Journey' was even harder to
understand
or maybe i'm just an idiot that said
thank you very much though
ok this is creepy, great
those look like very spiky rocks that
could kill me
I'm going to try my best not to die here
what are those and I'm not talking about
my weird ass lil' shoes
let's go inside..
that's cool man.. I will- goodbye little
buddy!
we're going to keep going to the next level!! To the next level!!
*barking*
all right all right all right!
whoa is this a snow map?
*laughs*
Underwater??
Duuude!
Just like fairy lights!
Fairy lights makes anything look pretty! Look at this..
You could literally slap fairy lights on
your mama's face and then she'd look good!
I was gonna say my face but.. fairy lights
wouldn't save my face..
whoa! how you doing there buddy?
hey you got a little-
ah that's cute!
that's adorable!
you kind of freaked me out though.. I
guess.. I guess we're gonna ride and we're
gonna ride I'm gonna ride I'm gonna ride
we're gonna ride we're gonna ride our
Aren't we gonna ride?
THIS IS COOL!!
I wanna do this..
Never mind i don't
wanna do this- that's terrifying
that's way too many whales!
Oh God! That's the mouth.. they're so big!
please don't eat me!
Woww!
holy shit!
whales are terrifying! I don't know why
they're just way too big..
ok? It scares me!
oh my hey y'all you almost hit me there
buddy
close call dude... I'm trying to save the
ocean here
oh Mama Mia
Wow
ah
where we going? where we going? We're at the bottom
ok all right. Sand makes me feel safe
Sand makes me feel safe. This is so cool
ok i am well into this
let me just make sure that i'm actually
recording. Sorry was i going to i am ok
great
let's keep going
what is that sound
What are those?
I hate how I can't say "what are those" anymore
without triggering that meme
WOAH, what just happened?!
well I'm never gonna be curious again
thank you very much
a Goblin Shark
Goblin plus shark sounds horrific. What
about this one?
they're like mines or something
oh shit that's a big ass skeleton
wow.. front flip
Ow ow
it's a little crab there... This game is so
detailed. It's amazing like a little
digletts too. I love diglett. Favorite pokemon
hands up
oh no it's freaky ass fishes. I hate them
like the deep-sea fishes
oh wow ok what is this? Is that a rock or
what is it???
Is it a skeleton on a rock? Whoa
Pkay we got a shell. This is so crazy
A lot of dead whales down here, boy. A lot of dead whales...
I bet QBone is going to come out.
That would make no sense whatsoever
oh god you scared me... Ok there's
something here
Go away mines! And Digletts. How you doing
buddy?
Ah here we go! There we go! Angler fish. I
know- That's the one I was talking
about the creepy looking ones
yeah fuck those. Sorry why did I help release hell up on this earth?
Ooh we got a cable! We got a cable if you get
ahhhhhhh
oh these are fucking creepy dude. Try not get ourselves killed. Jesus dude
yeah that's right y'all don't fuck with me.
I'm the cable guy. Ok one more cable then I suppose. Cool now we have a purpose.
Now we know what to do. Get the other
cable and fast
I'm gonna go so fast. Bapadadadada
that's my sound effect to make myself go
faster. Trust me Sonic uses it.
Everyone uses it.
Uh world famous athletes use it
Aw shit. Oh God. All right. How could I not
see this?
Oh god I'm gonna die. I literally going to die. I'm literally going to die.. I'm alive i'm alive
Aaahhh
It's so loud! Alright it just stings a
little bit! it's like a Pikachu sneeze.
I'm playing way too much pokemon go
thank you everyone
there we go. We open the giant gate in
the bottom of the ocean
What are we gonna find? I don't know!
Awww it's dat fucka. He ate my (some pokemon idk)
shut up about the pokémon. fucking hell...
sorry
Front flip. Hey! Super speed!
Look at that! you've got to front flip and
then get speed. How did I do that?
Whoa! Flipping makes it speed man shit
shit
go go go flip dude
yeah yeah golden! Golden fishes! Oh there it is!
oh well I guess you're fucked now huh? Have
you thought about that Mr.shark?
you should have thought of-
Oh you want my help now? Well you should have thought
about that before you ate my friend! look at this front flip
look at this front flip! Bet you can't do
shit. Alright fine. I'll save you, Jesus Christ
all right just promise that you won't eat me
oh boy yeah I fucked up now. Oh no! We're swimming with sharks everyone!
that's cool
ok well the guy in the game is clearly
insane
I would never do this
look at that golden shoes man. Heyyy that's
a shell
that's a shell. If I didn't take that
shell everyone watching me play this
would freak the fuck out. On a- Hey, I got a cat here. I just realized that's
really cute
Kawaii~ I just realized that no- so
many times, I noticed that I'd
missed something in the playthrough while
I edit it and I know everyone's gonna
want to kill me
it's like it physically hurts you guys
if I missed something
Sometimes I want to miss stuff on purpose. Oh
god you guys are ugly whales
I don't like you guys
Woahh
ok we're going deeper everyone thank you.
Oh no those octopuses....
oh I'm cringing for real
oh I hate those... Have you guys watched
those like deep water
uhhhh fuckin ohhh. They find this huge ass
octopuses. They're so scary
I'm swimming to it. I'm legit cringing. Sorry sorry just don't go near me.
Oh God. The the deep ocean terrifies me
man you don't - you don't even know what's
down there
We don't even know! We don't even know
what's down there!
Think of all the ugly creatures!
I mean it's beautiful. Everything in this
game is beautiful. I-I'm so sorry.
Just those octopuses. I can't. Is that what they're called? Octopuses?
All right it's time to give this place
some life.
I think this could be our last or second
last.. I am not sure.
Let's have a look... One... Two... Three
This is our last. How is that possible?
what?
super speed
Heyyy look at that trick man. You just got to do a different one
I think to get it. No? There it is!
Totally hit that! Surely there's a last
one after this one.
Don't worry okay I got this. Papa Pewds got this
Aw no. I'm not down with this. I'm not down
with those octopuses.
You know if I'm, if I'm bad in this life, I'm going to be reincarnated as one of those.
and it's not gonna be good man
it's not some... oh god.
It's a lot of underwater stuff recently.
I just watched a Finding Dory as well
Aw man. It makes me want to go to the Brighton aquarium. Marzia would be
thrilled. She literally wants me to go
every day.
Okay. Flip! Heyyy super speed. Oh these sharks are following me.
Excellent. Excellent. We're going deeper. We
going deeper through the tiny little
hole. Going deeper. These sexual
innuendos write themselves. I don't even-
Oh god. What is that?
How did that get there? How am I supposed
to get through? I think that's the
real question.
We're just going to speed up
Gimme speed gimme speed. Ahhh it looks
so fucking cool.
I mean I'm know I'm not here to fucking comment about the bad things
Jesus that looks awesome. Such different
styles combining? I really like it
Dude you got to keep swimming then.
Do the foot. There we go!
That went pretty well! Next level
We'll do one more. We'll do one more. I'm really into this and I want to keep
playing.
Oh my god this is the end of Star Fox 64
which was essentially ripped off from
Star Wars
You know what I'm talking about. This is
so cool
There you go take another shot everyone
yeah
whoa
Some kind of conveyor belt building
half-light to uh half-light 3 confirm shit
Can't hit me
Why do those things react to me?
That's the real question
There we go. Found something.
What is that? Is that the propeller thing? It is!
It's got those things in them.
And that's in the shit so the last one
is in here maybe
Oh shit this is the matrix now. It turned
into the matrix... and that's me and I have
one in me
Oh god that can't be good.
Guys back up. Oh they're with me.
Ok cool. Maybe this is my spaceship?
Oooh
That'd be interesting.
Well regardless we're going to keep
going.
Here we go smooth like butter. But... not a problem.
whoa whoaaaaa
well that's a lot of things to go
through man
oh boy, oh boy. Uh get a- oh shit, they're down everywhere. They're everywhere. They're everywhere
They're everywhere.
Okay okay we're gonna take this route.
We're gonna take the route. We're gonna
do the chicken wrap. Aah oh shit, I
gotta go up ah ok alright alright
alright i know dude i know that we got
to go there but do they
they're fucking everywhere man i can't
even see where I'm going man ahh
Ah ah ehhh. Don't shoot me! No no no! Ahhhhhh that fucking hurts man.
The cur- AHHHHH SHIETTTT
make it stop
MAKE IT STOP. We got a window! We got a window! wegotawindow!
wegotawindow! Aw shit they're blinking everywhere.
they're blinking everywhere. Gogogogogogogogo.
I'm trying to fucking go forward!
Then you go backwards!
I'm sweating!
Do the swimming fast thing!
(horrid screaming) up left down right!
Press be AIT's like start ok ok
we did it. Well Jesus Christ dude. I did that so easily
that was- that was pathetic of how easily
I did that.
well hello there little friend
shit it's the mastermind. it's a self-aware
computer isn't it?
Sharky Sharky save me
oh no oh this is a bad one.
that's why Sharkey killed the drone!
Sharkey's on my side!
Oh I'm so sorry
I'm an idiot. I'm an idiot. sharkey's on my
side all along.
okay bros. I'm gonna have to end it
there. This game is absolutely incredible!
Last part is going to be the last one so
make sure you don't miss it
it'll be up tomorrow! I promise you! Thank
you so much for leaving a like!
That really supports and helps out
and as always, stay awesome bros!
(random noises and funky music)
or whatever.
don't known.
What are these?
jumping sliding whoaaaaa haha alright!